damit nico hofmann gerade gehört in
dieser beeindruckenden persönlichen
situationen auch gerade wie offen ehren
der familie es geschafft hat und auf zu
arbeiten oder leben dann den anderen
fall gerade matthias schweighöfer der
diese prominente rolle des ss schlecht
dass klaus barbie gerade spielt und uns
gegenüber zumindest sich verwehrt hat im
moment an die persönliche eigene
geschichte heran zu gehen warum sagst du
ist das so wichtig diese persönliche
biografie auf zu haben ja ich glaube
matthias schweighöfer macht gerade den
fehler das glaube ich falsch sich dazu
öffentlich nicht zu äußern weil es
geschichtsvergessen wirkt obwohl er
gleichzeitig jetzt sozusagen mit einem
film einen schrecklichen teil der
geschichte beleuchtet ich weiß auch gar
nicht genau ob er sich nicht wirklich
schon damit beschäftigt hat und nur
nicht öffentlich darüber reden will ich
traue ihm wirklich so viel
intellektualität zu und so viel
menschlichkeit dass er das getan hat
trotzdem werden riesige chance jetzt
darüber zu sprechen um genau diesen
diskurs zu führen den nico hofmann
geführt hat im zuge seines filmes und
auch heute weitergeführt hat das ist
glaube ich sogar
bürgerpflicht ich glaube es ist eine
bürgerpflicht für jeden deutschen sich
auch mit der eigenen familiengeschichte
auseinanderzusetzen und sie zu verstehen
und daraus für sich konsequenzen zu
ziehen das kann ja sogar sein dass eine
konsequenz des matthias schweighöfer aus
der geschichte seines vaters ist dass er
jetzt in einem solchen film eine solche
rolle spielt um derzeit noch immer die
zeit nochmal zum leben zu erwecken in
der diese schrecklichen taten passiert
sind um diese schrecklichen geschehnisse
zu geschichte wurden und das alles mit
den deutschen mit den zuschauern heute
den riesige chance in amerika ist zu
gast bei jimmy fallon der berühmtesten
amerikanischen talkshow mit den menschen
diese eigene aufarbeitung zu teilen
hätte glaube ich mindestens so eine
chance bedeutet zu werden wie das bei
nico hofmann und seinem film gewesen ist
und auch manchen anderen ich beklage ihn
nicht an aber ich sage schon deutlich es
ist falsch und man muss von einem
vorbild eigentlich erwarten können dass
auch diese bürger pflicht nachkommt
vorbild sein heißt nicht nur den besten
tisch in einem edelrestaurant zu kriegen
weil man berühmt ist er berühmt sein und
vorbild sein heißt auch sich seiner
verantwortung und der eigenen geschichte
zu stellen du glaubst das ist eine
vertane chance werden die kurve gerade
gehört ja sagt man darf sich damit auch
privat auseinandersetzen jetzt sagst du
aber er ist ja matthias schweighöfer
keine private person er könnte diese
zeit jetzt nutzen diese rolle und auch
die vergangenheit seines großvaters um
anderes ich glaube dass ich glaube das
macht auch sozusagen die kritik führung
aus wenn er nicht in dieser öffentlichen
situation wäre dann ist das wahr was
nico hofmann sagt da aber sich in dieser
öffentlichen situation befindet ist es
aus meiner sicht falsch und eben eine
vertane chance und sozusagen jeder
erfahren auch angedeutet ich habe bei
mir ist es sozusagen die perspektive des
großvaters der als wehrmachtssoldat
sowohl an der ostfront als auch an der
westphal zum einsatz kam aus heutiger
sicht würde man wahrscheinlich sagen als
kanonenfutter das damals überlebt und
hat den dialog mit mir als ich ganz
klein war gab es den dialog nicht ich
meine es in man den habe ich geliebt und
ich weiß wie schwer das war überhaupt
dann als ich in der schule und im
gespräch mit meinen eltern über die zeit
erste informationen bekommen habe immer
mitlaufen zu haben da war opa
beteiligten welche rolle hatte er und
wie schwer es war dieses gespräch zu
kommen und ich gebe auch zu dass ich
manchmal mit ihm auf dem sofa saß und
dachte jetzt müsste ich eigentlich
ansprechen aber ich konnte nicht mal das
ja mein opa und er selber wollte
sozusagen darüber auch nicht sprechen
und dann aber es wahrscheinlich auch
viel erlebt haben was ja fast schon
sprichwörtlich ist opa erzählt vom krieg
immer weihnachten nach zwei drei gläsern
wein erzählt er die immer gleichen
geschichten schreckliche geschichten die
geschichten wie er das stand und rechts
und links seine beiden besten freunde
gefallen sind und er sich immer mit der
frage konfrontiert warum die beiden und
nichtig wie wir das stand und im
lichtkegel einer leuchtkugel plötzlich
er meinte immer 10 15 meter von ihm
entfernt russische soldaten waren und
dann hörte er aber auf zu erzählen und
er erzählte weiter uns nur indem er
sagte und dann war es wieder dunkel und
alles war ruhig es ist ja klar was
passiert das erdgeschoss es ist ja klar
was da ist und er hat diese
auseinandersetzung aber nie so zu sagen
von sich aus betrieben und war dann
verschlossen sozusagen das irgendwie in
seinem herz oder sonstwo versiegelt du
hast also dieses gefühl das müsste ich
müssen wir aufarbeiten auch in der und
ich haben zwei klare konsequenzen für
mich daraus zwei lehrern die eine lehre
lautet dass ich sozusagen immer dafür
sorgen will achtsam zu sein dass so
etwas nie mehr geschieht der der
mechanismus aus dem heraus mein
großvater in die situation kann man dies
ist ein bisschen anders als nico hofmann
na klar war deren täter in einer armee
aber hätte desertieren sollen hat auch
immer beschrieben wie die deserteure
erschossen worden sind vielleicht hatte
das erfunden und nie selber gesehen um
sich selber sozusagen 1 ich konnte ja
nicht anders habe ich habe zwei sachen
mitgenommen mein leben das eine ist nie
wieder klar und das andere ist aber auch
die frage wie hätte ich mich damals
verhalten mit einer nötigen mit einem
nötigen respektvollen abstand näher zu
treten weil ich glaube wer heult sich
anmaßen zu sagen genau zu wissen wie er
sich damals verhalten hätte ist entweder
anmaßend oder ein furchtbarer
klugscheißer eine diskussion die ich zum
beispiel auch gerne mit matthias
schweighöfer hier in diesem studio jetzt
die chance eine könnte ist jetzt also
wenn er könnte es jetzt tun und das wäre
ehrlich gesagt die verdienstvollsten pr
arbeit von fünf filme die man machen
kann